oh always man
always a pleasure it's an honor it's an
honor to be with you
and oh gee of the game musha allah
someone has been in here for a long time
mashallah
alhamdulillah it's really nice
to connect with you especially i want to
commend you i want to commend the
sisters
dr madiha and yourself this is such an
important topic
and no i'm not totally agree totally
girl sorry go ahead go ahead
no no go ahead yeah it's such an
important topic and to see you know
someone like yourself
you know her she's taking you know such
being a strong voice
an advocate for you know uh health the
doctor here who's you know
uh helping to create this awareness and
you now stepping on board this
i it just you know it revives that
because i my story as you know
was one of just like most people you
know you're i was
always into martial arts physical
fitness but then i was eating whatever i
wanted to i wasn't really taking that
part serious and then
you go through those struggles and of of
chronic health issues and whatnot it
starts your body starts breaking down
and
then i alhamdulillah got turned out to
many of these things we'll be talking
about
and then i try to bring this stuff you
know create more awareness of it and
then to see people in the masjids
removing the coca-cola you know removing
the fake foods you know people to get on
board so i commend you you know for
being a voice for that
you know uh for this is so so important
i totally agree um you know mashallah
you know uh
it it's very very important you know
having my own personal experience and
then even with my family
you know seeing the effects of of health
and what you eat and having the three
elements right the eating
uh the sleeping and the type of movement
that is needed to improve your
well-being and your health uh
subhanallah i i know that it's very
crucial
and having someone and you know such as
yourself and everyone on this panel
and those that are viewing that take
this into high importance it's not
supplemental it's something that is
essential so
mashallah hats off to the sister may
allah reward her and increase her
and everything that she's doing from her
books to her her side to you know her
her
you know her insight and also her
knowledge and you as well i mean
mashallah being on the scene and being
an effective element to the community
is huge it's not something to be taken
lightly that's her book right there
really good book
and she's a really a good example for a
lot of other i mean doctors
to take the lead because doctors as you
know they don't study nutrition in
medical schools i mean this is not to uh
disparaging any doctors but this is just
it's like somebody
focusing on one meth head right but now
there's other meth heads or
you know there's a whole branch of
sciences in the dean so okay you
mastered one but there's this whole
other element this whole
other science of nutrition and she's
taking the next level she's got her
uh medical degree but she also went
above and beyond and started studying
nutrition
so this is so so important that's a
whole different branch you know
uh of science no no exactly man because
i mean you know one thing about myself
is also i don't know if you know but
before i went to go study
and even after when i came back i used
to work as a surgical tech so i used to
be in the or with
physicians of different services so
you'll find that the orthopedic surgeon
doesn't have that much i mean he has the
basic knowledge of what a cardiovascular
surgeon may
make may have you know but there's
definitely there's specializations
which could be uh you know uh a a as i
said a gift or a curse
being that they're specialized in one
thing but knowledge of something else
they may not and will not have so when
you're talking about nutrition that's a
whole other thing that we as
human beings sometimes you know they may
think that just kind of how you
mentioned with the motherhood you know
somebody that
comes in with the beard and the thought
and gives a hoot but is an islam and
knows
and knows all of it but that's not the
case so it's very important to take from
those that have the experience and the
knowledge as well so
it's a very good analogy that you've
given and it's important for us as human
beings and as
as muslims to know that you know uh this
holistic treatment holistic medicine and
nutrition
and diet is something that is there it's
a speciality and it requires people to
have knowledge
of of that field as well let me uh
bring some statistics here to the table
and i want to get your feedback
when you hear this what do you think
look what they're what they're telling
us here
we have a cdc report that more than 100
million americans today
have diabetes are pre-diabetic and
pre-diabetic means that probably in five
years they'll be
to having full-blown diabetes we have
the department of defense has labeled
chronic health an
existential threat to america
you have 30 percent of kids children
nowadays they have chronic disease
uh you have kids losing their teeth to
tooth decay
at that young age i mean god almighty
love made those teeth to last you know i
had a dentist on you know holistic
dentists and we were talking about this
some
you know some people get buried with
their original teeth if they take care
of them a lot didn't put a
you know a child it's a sad you know to
have to get root canals at you know at a
tender age of you know
seven eight nine which is happening so
we have that we have more
kids we have the sickest nation of kids
i hadn't even gotten to the adults yet
the sickest nation of kids than ever
they say that this is the first
generation of kids not expected to
outlive their parents
you have one in two americans with
chronic disease one in three
with multiple chronic diseases you have
40 percent
obese now when you combine the obese
with the overweight that's 70
you have one and two expected to have
cancer americans today i think one in
three women
and you have who the world health
organization 2013
it's an old statistic it's probably
grown exponentially
now they said 2.8 million people die
each year from being over weight
so and all this the majority
they say this comes from the food
choices
we make 95 percent of these
is said to come from the food choices
that we make
so you know all majority food
related what do you think when you have
that so there's a quote here by the
health ranger he said today more than 95
of all chronic diseases is caused by
food choice toxic food ingredients
nutritional deficiencies and a lack of
physical exercise
the health ranger when you hear that
what do you think
it's again it's something that is it
should not be taken lightly and the word
here i think that you know
we really need to take into account is
the word chronic
because you know we're thinking of a
sickness we're thinking of something
acute you know the difference being
chronic being over a long period of time
or lasting a long period of time
so when we think of that it's like okay
over a span of your lifetime
you know what you are eating you're
thinking okay well friday i ate the
pizza
you know or i had the ice cream well
it's something that could have happened
years ago that is slowly slowly piling
up
in your arteries you know on your heart
in your gut being your colon uh the
lining of your stomach
all this sugar that's being congested
that's been consumed
over a long over years and diabetes is
not something that comes overnight
you know what as i mentioned it was a
surgical tech and one of the the first
questions was does the patient have
diabetes
because it comes to you know we look at
the reality of the blood
you know reaching all of the you know we
say the limbs to a certain degree and
there are certain signs
of people having diabetes which i think
will be talked about but that's
that's huge when you hear the word
chronic it's important for us to know
that as they used to say when i was
young and i remember this it was you are
what you eat you are what you eat man
and that is so huge because
you will see the effects on your body
whether you
like it or as soon as you swallow it you
know whether you like it or not it's
going to have an
effect on you and you have no control
over the kind of effect
that it will have on you unless you take
the proper means and the best means is
just totally staying away
from that which is detrimental so that
that
those statistics are are huge and as you
mentioned you mentioned one side and you
said it's more likely to get worse
you know when looking at subhanallah our
society now we love
the modernity and we love the access and
instant
you know gratification but it comes with
a price it comes with a price
let's look to quran and sunnah i want to
mention one ayah here
and then we'll get into some hadith
in surah chapter 2 al-baqarah 172
it's very interesting look or god
almighty allah then you can go ahead and
and expound on this where he's saying
so all you who believe eat of the good
things
i have provided for you and be grateful
to allah if you uh if it is him you
worship why is allah
out of all this he is specifically
talking about look
eat of the good how would you translate
this word you got
good pure how would you go ahead and
expound on this ayah this is like
amazing out of all this all these verses
allah god almighty the creator is
talking about food exactly man and and
again you know if allah is just again
adjusting in the quran it's not
something that should be supplemental
yeah it's not something that should be
supplemental it is
essential and there's a huge difference
supplemental means that it's addition if
you do it or you don't you know it's not
a problem we could say like maybe uh
the nothing right and the salawat right
it is not obligatory but essential means
you have to have it
in your life in order to be your best
self or in order to be
someone that allah is pleased with or
that the manifestation of his
his preservation will take place so he
says
oh you believe it's a call it's a call
out to all of mankind call out to those
who believe
kulumin
yeah and that is that which is good or
that which is clean and the scholars
have
explained plaguey bat he explains it as
that which is clean
and pure and as we know during the time
of the prophet salallahu
you know what's so amazing you know all
of these words we hear organic
fat free all of these things the origin
of the food is that if you were to just
go into you know
slaughter an animal and and and cook it
as we as we see in
the ancient movies as something that is
shouldn't be done or something that is
barbaric
that is organic that is natural it eats
from the earth
and you eat from it and subhanallah and
that's what we call the
the animal that is the one that is just
free roaming
uh the earth without any type of
man-made
uh objects from the the seeds that it
eats and the fertilization and
pesticides that can tamper with the food
therefore being organic if it is free of
all of those things
so that is from the bats and that is
from what is clean and that is pure but
i think
it requires because of ultimately lies
ultimately the word greed and people
wanting money for having things longer
on the shelf
letting things having these
preservatives to preserve it
from decomposing the way allah has
created it to decompose quickly
that is where it tampers with the word
plagibat and it can
change the state of it taking it away
even some fruits from
tahibat so allah says when he you know
eat from this
what we have provided from you
subhanallah when we look at
you know farmers you know it just just
the whole concept of
agriculture and of itself is an amazing
concept from a worship standpoint from a
religious standpoint from
relying on the creator of the heavens
and the earth to bring down the rain
because if the rain does not come
without his provisions then you will not
have the crops that will grow
to further provide for you and your
family as we know from the barter system
i'll trade you
you know 10 cows for this amount of weed
or things of that nature
you know subhan allah so allah sponsors
to remind us
all that the origin of all this food is
what allah has provided and it is there
for you
as allah says
he is the one that has created
everything for you on this earth but as
i was mentioning to some young men
earlier today
and probably touch on this verse as well
you know that uh
the things on this earth it is how we
consume them
and use them that make them harmful or
impermissible
water can be the means to your own
destruction
as allah mentioned in the chapter of
talks about water coming from the sky
and water coming from springing from the
earth which caused the flood
but at the same time you need it for
wudu at the same time yes you
we made everything from water so
ultimately when we see that allah has
provided us
with the sluggy bats it is not for us to
tamper with it it is not for us to use
it for our own
worldly game and that's why if you are
those that truly believe
you thank him you're great you're
grateful to him and use it for that
which helps you into ibadah and no
better way to help yourself in ibadah
of the be of the better ways than eating
directly
from his provision so this is a direct i
like what you said i mean this is
this is from the crater that happens on
earth i mean this is to be taken serious
and it should be talked about more this
is very important especially i mean
we're talking about health
and we know the preservation of life is
so important and when we look at all
these chronic health issues i mean one
in two people look expected have cancer
can you imagine look
and now the majority of these are
reversible right so this goes back to
like again tying the camel
it goes back to what digging the trench
you know uh
this is something that we have in our
power and then you do your and then if
something hits you it hits you but you
have to do your part
and not just gorge and you know just
take it lightly
and and then the sickness comes and
you're just like you know
uh trying to chase a cure when this is
the preventative measures that we can
take let's go on to the next one
the hadith so this authentic hadith
where the prophet saws
said look the two blessings which people
they take for granted look he's talking
about spare time and
health why is the prophet saw mentioning
this look at his men health we're
talking about health he's
look this is the messenger of allah
final messenger sent to mankind the two
things that people take for granted the
most despair time and
health why is he talking about this
yeah he says
you know he says it is a blessing
and to realize that what allah has given
you
trust you know uh
you know subhanallah when we say um
the trust from allah some scholars even
mention
in regards to selling your body part
is it allowed to sell it if you're you
know for means of monetary gain now just
just generally speaking i mean not
speaking
by any particular issue if someone may
be in a dire need of things that nature
and you'll find some of the scholars say
uh the reason
behind their claim of impermissibility
which is beautiful they say because it
is not your body part anyway
it isn't a manner it has been given to
you temporarily
it is what allah has given you and how
are you treating that trust
you know even when a child is born you
know we have the akika
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
mentions he mentions the newborn as a
mortal
it is that which allah has given you and
he plans to take
him or her back so understanding that
this body that we have been given
ultimately we do not have ultimate
control over it
if you think about it so when you have
it how are you treating it
and that is where this comes in we
should realize the importance
of our health because when we are i mean
subhanallah we are still in the in the
covered era right now
all of us have witnessed subhanallah
how you don't have control over your own
self
you can't just snap your finger and say
you know what i don't i don't want covet
anymore
you know but what you're doing at the
moment is
man was it probably my immune system was
it the way that i've eaten
was it the fact that i wasn't consuming
cruciferous vegetables
i wasn't drinking water i wasn't having
some type of movement
i wasn't sleeping at an adequate time do
you want to be full of regrets
and that's why this hadith is so
beautiful beautiful because
these two things we are highly
neglectful we stay up at night
right and that's the staying up at night
eating junk food
right so it's kind of like contradictory
to the blessing that allah has given you
but again it goes back to realizing and
third of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala when
you remember
allah you remember your creator you
remember the blessings and manifestation
of his lordship
upon you and from that is giving you
this amount in this this
body and this health and this time to
use it in a in a
grateful way yeah it's uh it's real sad
many people have been affected by this
disease that you brought up
but it's even sadder that now these
things that people
aren't taking the reality of look this
immune system this amazing immune system
it's either you're weaking weakening it
day by day or you're strengthening it
and you don't hear
you know even many of the medical
professionals they don't talk about
like people like madiha said and people
in her class people who are gone above
me
they talk about this so that's that
method let's say for example say they
that they take this approach but
conventional medicine they don't talk
about strengthening the immune system
they don't talk about the power you know
you don't really hear this
in this approach so this is something
like okay we're taking many people are
taking these precautions and they're
putting on you know the
mask and this this all this other okay
you're doing that that's fine but
all these other things components that
are so more important because the people
who are being affected the most
are usually the people statistically who
have these underlining health issues
yeah so so now you know what we're
talking about here
you know the the the health aspect are
things that are going to be
strengthening you're strengthening the
gift that allah gave the immune system
that army that's able to insha allah
fight off and nobody's against medicine
and doing all these things but your
first line of defense is your
your immune system your body so what are
you putting in your body to strengthen
your army or to weaken your body
exactly no it's beautiful man i mean
just exactly how you're putting it
you know subhanallah you know when you
get a cut when you when you when you
when you you know you cut yourself or
you're cut you get bruised
allah has already created a mechanism
for your body to heal itself immediately
immediately but but the problem is is we
take it for granted because we're so
used to it
yeah oh yeah it's gonna clot up or you
know inshallah you know what i'm sleepy
i'm drowsy
your body is telling you something even
mucus in and of itself is a protective
mechanism
it's not and it can be a sign of the
lack of certain nutrients
or it can be a sign of certain nutrients
and certain chemicals that shouldn't
even be in your body
so you know allah subhanallah gives you
many ayat
he gives you many ayat and many signs
but the person should take heed even
when you look in the mirror and you may
see some
blemishes or something on your face one
of the first questions one should ask is
okay what did what have what have i been
eating
right what have i been eating because
food is the i remember upon allah when i
started you know i came back from saudi
arabia you know and started working out
and stuff and one of my mentors when i
was working out i was like okay
i what you know you always hearing what
protein shake and
you know and all this stuff he was like
man food man he said
food is the best medicine eat
clean that's it just eat clean don't get
into all of this other stuff
just eat clean everything comes from
that and mankind puts their own
intervention in their own uh you know
chemicals on top of that
you have to be assuming you know they
they they
cow or they they they cover that which
is true
with which is untrue even though the
context is slightly different but to
show that
you know that which is pure you know
they place they adulterate that which is
pure
let food be your medicine and medicine
be your food it's a statement for
hippocrates this is uh
so so important let's go one more hadith
where the prophet saws lasted found a
message sent to mankind prophet muhammad
peace and blessed be upon him he said
take advantage of five before
five all right so what do you have in
there [ __ ] you had uh
time before uh you're overwhelmed with
time uh
age right before old age hits hits in
your wealth before you lose it and
there's two more in there i miss uh we
got before we get to hell what was the
other one
and then you have health so health
health isn't it when it comes to that
comes to us but
health is one of those five before five
again
health he's talking about health [ __ ]
no subhanallah again and and if you
notice all of these have the imperative
verb
you know it's
take advantage of five you know so it's
taking it take advantage of it using the
imperative verb to show
the matter of importance the matter of
subhanallah
importance is this this is preventative
right before it hits
beautiful exactly exactly and you know
subhanallah as they say
in in arabic
prevention is better than cure you know
that one has the wakaya it takes the
preventative measures
and the the the seed of preventative
measures
is when you i don't think how much i
don't think we realize
uh you know we use we think of the word
jihad you know but people
who have part with guns and you know and
all the black flag and all that or we
think of jihad enoughs
okay but one of the most important
manifestations of jihad enough
is when you when you open that
refrigerator man
when you open that cover what choices
are you making
you know how often is just do you turn
your stove on to actually cook something
as opposed to
going in the freezer and getting
something that has that's breaded and
when you look at the ingredients
you think it's another language because
you're seeing so many words that you
know
that you have to study uh even more more
than nutrition
to understand what some some of these
words mean when you're in the kitchen
that is when you should ask a lot we're
lying
this sounds may sound outlandish or
far-fetched
that's when you should ask allah for
toffee when you walk in your kitchen
to make the right decisions when you go
to the store
you know to make sure that you stop by
the produce section and buying water
so taking advantage of that the
manifestation of it i would say that all
of us
you know uh uh face is when we walk in
the kitchen
kitchen that is where the protection of
the
and the implementation of this hadith if
we have our correct intention we will
receive reward for it inshallah
they say the hardest push-up that one
will ever do is to push that plate away
or to push those sweets away
that's the hardest push-up one could do
so you gotta
you really gotta be strong let's go this
is a famous scholar look
and um i hope the fans of uh sheikh um
ibn al-qaim uh they will really be
attentive
i found this quote for him i don't know
if you ever heard this one
and i want your comments on it he said
it's
a tribute to him that health is one of
the most precious favors
allah has bestowed upon his servants the
most generous of gifts
the most plentiful of his bounties
rather even more health is the most
precious of favors without exception
so it is fitting that whoever is granted
a portion of this
fortune that he cherishes it preserves
it and guards it
against harm what do you think about
that when you hear that brilliant i mean
just
yeah that is that is brilliant
he's someone that is uh he's talking
about
look at look what he's taught you know
look how he's balancing it out he's
talking about all the different uh
sciences of the slide and then he's
talking about
look this do you think we're lacking of
this talking about this by many of uh
some of the learned folk amongst us oh
oh big time and again that's why you
know subhanallah even okay
you know i'm trying to think of which
book he said in because he talks about
this in numerous books
right in subhanallah you know there's
the book that we have nebui
which is you know it's it's a part of of
of his book so when we're looking at
the beautiful aspect of the you know ibm
capitalizing on this
is the student of sheikh islam in tamiya
you know uh in
from syria so from the mosque so when
when looking at
this statement of ibm rahimahullah
of it and how he talks about preserving
it and it's a trust from allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala
you know we know we should firstly
understand as we mentioned in the
beginning
that this is something that is essential
to our existence
as muslims but most importantly as human
beings i.e
taking care of our bodies by watching
what we
eat primarily watching what we eat and
how we
treat our bodies and you know
subhanallah you know i remember um
there's a hadith of the prophet saws he
talks about is all of us have heard you
know
the third you know the the the three
elements that a third should be for
error a third for
fluid and a third for food and ibn rajab
he mentions in his explanation of this
hadith and the
general hickam in his book explanation
of the after hadith
he mentions that a non-muslim physician
during his time
said if this hadith were to be
implemented
basically saving a third for water a
third for food and a third for drink
that the hospitals and clinics that we
wouldn't there would be no need for them
because if people were to practice this
and in the way and the amount that they
eat
from this aspect of obviously eating
that which is slave
then we wouldn't have any need for these
clinics etc
let me just again go back to my story
maybe you have a similar story you can
share with us
and maybe some people can relate again
so i was talking about someone who's
always
you know working out and to martial arts
but then kind of
just eating gorging you know what i mean
having those sometimes would be like
just cheat day but then you know maybe a
whole box of donuts or whatnot
and then you start having teeth issues
you start having health issues and then
you go
to you know the doctor and then he gives
you some antibiotics and you think okay
i feel good
and then you get sick again the week
that you weak you're weakening the
immune system just eating garbage
and you start having bronchitis or you
know some other
health issues and whatnot and that's
what i was having
and then that routine i would just you
know you watch the
commercials back in the day when you
when you used to watch the tv and you
you see like you know the pharmaceutical
drugs they're pushing out there so
you know we're i think one of the two
only two countries i think new zealand
and america
that allow the pharmaceutical company to
advertise
right to the people directly so this is
dangerous why they say because now
you're fixated in that pill because the
marketing is hitting you and now you
force doctors get put in a position
that now you go to them and they gotta
you know give you something that you
want something you want this pill and
that's and
then it'll educate you a doctor should
be an educator educating you on how to
have better health so they need to give
you a pill because you believe there's a
pill for every ill and that's how i was
you brainwashed you know into that
but then you start to see it stops it's
not working you know you're just masking
the problem it's just kind of an example
that's given is like someone who has
a rock in their shoe and then they got
pain and then you go
you know to the doctor because the pain
but it gives you ibuprofen but you
didn't get the rock out of the shoe
right if you just get to the root of the
problem so i wasn't getting to the root
of the problem
but allah guided me to a nutritionist
his name was jim marlow
while he was a former nutritionist for
uh for
a doctor who's really popular in the
health scene dr mercola he was his chief
nutritionist
and then he turned me out to you know
eating real food you know the thai bat
we call it
and then i started to see major changes
happen and
things started to really get better as
far as health alhamdulillah
but one of the first things that i cut
out
and alan carr talks about this he's had
great success
he's uh award-winning author of getting
people off of alcohol cigarettes smoking
and he has a book called good sugar bad
sugar
and he talks about in his book that will
power will only take you so far
right you have to unpackage what you've
been brainwashed
all over these years as a child and
specifically we're talking about here
what
helped me is when i went to war on sugar
now
we differentiate the good sugar that
allah put in dates
and apples and you know the real foods
that come with
fiber has a nutritional value uh
micronutrients in there
and we're talking about not that but the
sugar that's been stripped from the
sugar cane that has no nutritional value
that's depleted of vitamins and minerals
and actually is poison it wrecks havoc
in the body
so when i studied that and i realized
that this stuff is poison it's actually
there's no
as alan carr talks about in his book
there's no safe level it's like someone
wants to take some some heroin you'll be
like there's no safe level that because
every time
you take you just set yourself up to
getting more and more addicted there's a
ton of research that talks about
it's more addictive to cocaine so
there's no no safe level
every time you put it or you project
your sugar cravings onto your children
you're setting them up for disaster and
we talked about the
the the staggering uh statistics and
whatnot
uh and then you're setting yourself up
for addiction and that's what it does it
gets you addicted and then you just want
more you have more and more and more
and then inflames your body as as uh
madiha talks about in her book uh
uh in this book the holistic rx so that
was the first thing so i want to talk
about that
you know going to to war on some of
these things
that you see when you alter the creation
of allah
you know it can produce many of these
negative results the food that allah
gave us
you know you mentioned the one third one
third now you go in moderation with that
but but these other these other like
they have
over a half a million fake food items
and they're all pumped in
the majority with with sugar so many
people don't know where to start so i
would recommend and
i'm see your thoughts on that
understanding un-packaging really
the difference between good sugar bad
sugar the sugar that allah gave us
right and dates and our raw honey this
kind of sugar is different
and then understanding what man has
concocted and made in the lab
and how this if we avoid this and i i've
had people people i have
you know people who've asked me you know
uh what was the thing that helped me the
most and once they've cut out sugar
they've seen a drastic decrease
in in their um weight loss right away
off the bat you know uh you can watch so
many different
videos out there of people who've given
up you know who've done this
and they've seen tremendous uh health
benefit and
turns around just from this just from
going to war
and understanding the havoc that is
wrecking on your body
and starting with that getting rid of
sugar cleaning out the cupboards
from sugar replacing with with other
what is
with something that you can substitute
it with but understanding is constant
what do you what do you think about that
no that's huge man i mean i just wanted
to hear you keep going because that that
is something that is
that was a breakthrough for me man i
mean
you know knowing what when they say
sugar okay
i'm thinking the white sugar in my
cupboard
i don't sit and eat that i don't put
that in my if i drink tea
i don't put that in my tea i don't put
that in you know
you know i remember i used to put that
in my cereal when i was younger i don't
do that anymore so okay
i used to do it also you know look at
any cornflakes by themselves man come on
come on man no so you know i used to
think it was
the white sugar but then you know
subhanallah
you know shout out to these two sisters
they were sisters uh
here in dallas a couple years ago and
they told me you know they were eating
some
some noodles but it wasn't processed
noodles right and i was like why and
they're like well there's there's a lot
of sugar i'm like there's sugar
in and and processed food and then
breaded foods and they're like
yeah so there was a doctor many i
watched called fed
but linguistically it revealed to me
the reality of sugar what sugar is in
like you know barbecues i used to love
barbecue sauce
like you know the the the hines and the
ketchup and
when i stopped and looked at what i
loved as a child and what took me to
made me go to the dentist in the fourth
grade and get so many fillings
you know i didn't eat the you know i had
the jolly ranchers you're thinking the
candy and the store
but no the sauces that you eat
bread you know all of these sugar is
inside of these things and what does
that mean
like when someone told me inflammation
i'm like okay inflammation on my joint
no then when you explain inflammation
and how that prohibits the absorption of
nutrients that you need and then what
can take place i think that general
education
what what's being done today from the
muslim um
as well needs to be done on a consistent
basis because when you talked about
sugar man
that is i don't know that is the seed
because a lot of people do not know
when we say sugar where it is in the
foods that we eat i mean
i think bread is one of the biggest ones
right bread food
is awesome i don't eat bread yeah
exactly right and you know when i left
bread
dairy let's just say dairy you know the
traditional dairy which they told us we
needed how many servings
you know uh per day when i left that i
saw a
drastic change in my body
i was i used to be lethargic in the
middle of the day because i would have
those little you know
healthy crackers and cookies and stuff
and realize that you know the sugar was
in it that is what was spiking me up and
then i was coming right back down
you know uh the feeling in my joints you
know when i wake up
in the morning you know it's kind of
leaving this sugar off
and and ultimately fasting uh was that
which which was huge and that again
you know when we're talking about
chronic illness sugar plays a huge role
in that and i think they talked about it
and planned to talk about it in the
future
from the walls in your artery to the
walls in your intestine
you know to supple uh to the way that
you your the clout the cloudiness and
your thoughts and the fog in your
thinking
you know sugar plays a huge role in that
and again it may not be tomorrow
but it could be 10 years from now 20
years from now and like you said
the average physician won't be able to
uncover that like you mentioned
someone that is a nutritionist and looks
at you know the elements of foods and
how it affects your hormonal system
primarily is that which is which is very
very important so i think
you know some of the action items for
muslims is to really you know after
today if they haven't is to look at
okay what are the good sugars that i can
eat and when should i eat them
and what are the things that i should
stay away from the bad sugars the
process when we say processed food what
does that mean
right so i think that's huge much a lot
for for bringing that up
yeah this this people don't understand
uh we talked about how
it creates the diabetes cardiovascular
disease
cancer obesity uh high blood pressure
weight gain
even has uh effect on your mental health
mood disorders
inflammation the list goes on your
logical disorders
all rating back to you know sugar and
it's i'm i just i'm so happy elated when
when you uh you start mentioning you're
talking about
many of these things it's kind of like
you you're you're
on the method now you're in the
manhattan they say you're understanding
because you've done you've just taken
some time
you've got an open mind as the saying
goes look for the mind to work it has to
function properly has to be like a
parachute has to be open
some people start talking about this
stuff and they're just like they're
living
to eat instead of eating or eating to
live instead of
living to or uh eating to to live
so living to eat yeah yeah you know the
saying right yeah
well now it's like they're not
taking this matter serious and this is
sad you know and then you see
look um like what i talked about many of
the
how it's been systematically set up
because then you go you get into the
system you don't want to get into the
system like when you go to for instance
the hospital i was there with my
nutritionist and we did a video
you know just uh pointing out some of
these things like it said on the
so we're in the waiting room and then
there's a sign says uh
something about nutrition and then we go
in there and it's a pop machine
right and and then it has the other
machine next to it with all the chips
and all of the
this is in a hospital so just this is
the ironic thing so then i i just had
recently had some
uh situation going back to the hospital
because because my father had a stroke
may allah heal him
i mean and then so
here true story look they so they bring
them in you're kind of at the mercy
there at the hospital
and then he gets in and he's already
diabetic and then they're
they're bringing him the jello and
they're bringing him the you know the
pop and the sp
and all and then this is increasing his
you know uh blood
blood pressure his uh blood sugar and
then he gets in a spiral of drugs you
know what i mean is
and that drug is causing this side
effect and that one this side effect and
it's just a roller coaster disaster you
know what i mean
yeah yeah no no man i don't mean to stop
you man but i'm just saying that you
know
yesterday i just had to bring take my
bring my mother back from the hospital
you know subhanallah she you know
because she they her cardiologist said
she had some issues with her heart so we
took her to the hospital and
she went in they were about to put a
stent in her but apparently there was no
stenosis everything was apparently
uh clean there but you know she had a
sharp pain in her chest i mean signs of
that which could lead to a heart attack
um you know she has vertigo you know
where it's the feeling of feeling dizzy
and you can't you know it's it's uh
you know sometimes it's in the middle
ear where you can't even you you're off
your equilibrium
you know so you know just seeing how
vulnerable she was post
after the after the presumed surgery
right or intervention because the
anesthesia was wearing off
and just seeing how subhanallah how
vulnerable she was
you know i'm saying to myself and you
know man inshallah may allah protect her
and do not want to be put in this
situation ever so just thinking about
you know the average person think about
okay working out something i can go out
and do which is great which is needed
but again you know subhanallah when they
were
bringing the food in you have to be you
know
and as you mentioned you'll tell certain
people the majority of people and they
don't it's not that they don't want to
hear that maybe polite
and sometimes even joke about it you
know that you're a health nut or
something like this
but the reality is you know they're
comfortable
what is more comfortable than eating
something that tastes good
you know so and and that's exactly the
the whole theme of the sharia
you know when you look in the deen of
islam
what's the one that what's the reason
the prophet even mentioned
why gold is impermissible for men he
says because it will be for you and
jenna
when he talks about jinn he talks about
rivers of of of honey lakes of milk
things and things that you know you will
desire
right but the goal is be patient and and
and
and fight your desires of that which is
not beneficial for you on this earth or
what let's even say what allah has made
him permissible
and you may not ultimately know all the
reasons but just doing it because allah
said so
he will give you that which you want in
the next life and from that is eating
from the
bath and not tampering with the food so
subhanallah you know and that's the
message i want to give to everyone i'm
glad you brought that up
in hospitals sometimes in gatherings
you're going to be the odd person out
people are going to look at you strange
people are going to you know
maybe even make fun of you you know uh
you may
like in hospitals just as you were as i
was you know they brought the food and
i'm like can i just work at the hospital
i'm like i asked him i said still
bad food in the hospital thank right
i mean in the hospital you know so it's
just you you you have to be that person
you know and i i say that with full
conviction to be the person that
always tries to call people to help
people and you know again like with
eating
it's something that they consume every
day so you're trying to tamper with that
you know i don't you know people don't
really want to hear that all the time
but when it comes to the being sick you
know when you
when you tell them okay what you what
you what you're eating
you know that's where it's kind of like
it's a final frontier for a lot of
people
yeah that's that's interesting you're
saying i mean we often um
we um again going back to the the
hospital i mean we do have like for
emergency care you break a leg
gun shot you know the best emergency
care but you know doctors would tell us
even i've had people
doctors on the program and people who
i've you know went to nutrition health
and i've asked them when's the last time
you've been to the doctor and this is
also what had me thinking
and i've had people say 20 years 25
years i said what
i thought that was just like you got to
be there like every once a year you
gotta
but it was like what are you doing like
what are the life hacks
and then they talk about what we're
talking about the key to good health is
good food
we haven't even got to exercise that's
part of it also but even before that
because
people get into this calorie counting
and whatnot but really i mean you can't
compare the
the calories from a avocado versus
snicker bar
it's not the same so you'll be you can
see people just working out day and
night
like i was myself working out a lot but
then again if you're putting goes back
to if you're putting
you know like my my uncle he was a
doctor chiropractor he said you know
allah god almighty didn't create the
bodies of the garbage can so don't put
garbage in it so if you're putting
garbage in it and you could be just
working not working out
but you're just it's counterproductive
right
yeah so uh going back to that is i'm
just so happy when you when you when you
mention that so we're trying to save i
mean can this fall under look you know
this is
helping to save life you know this is
something that we know about really
helping to save the
the children who are not expected to
outlive their parents
you know the cancer is just growing
exponentially
chronic disease and and what we found
you found i found in the doctors who are
on this panel and
whatnot on this program so this is just
to like for for the ummah for the
community and beyond to take the matter
serious one
you know get the coca-cola out of the
masjids i mean
it's something real and then well i get
again this is not to put you know
disparage or until we have some
doctors physicians out there but it
really disheartening when i come in and
i've seen this and i'm like
i'm around and there's like a whole
group of physicians at the table
and they got coca-cola on the table
yeah yeah no subhanallah i mean
especially in ramadan i mean as
you know it's a huge opportunity to
quote unquote jump start
dare i say your life uh your your body
and the metabolism and the functionality
of your hormones primarily
you know the insulin uh secretion you
know which is the key hormone to to
weight gain ultimately right when you
break your fast your body is so depleted
of nutrients and wants to
you know what immediately what you
consume is what's going to take in
and even hold to a certain degree so if
it's going to be you know what you're
breaking your fast with is something
that you can practically
have a real good jump start in and make
sure that it's something that is light
and that is natural that is slightly
something that is light natural to
call organic and free of all pesticides
and anything any type of chemicals
you know rather than uh pop i think
you'll call it so you know soda
uh and some salty foods you know
subhanallah
so that's one thing okay we can we can
one
like some action do items clean your
house off from all of the sugar the
processed foods the fake foods and fake
foods often say is a list of food with
ingredients
you need a chemistry degree a biology
degree to understand to
you know to pronounce so cut all that
out because you're going to be
less tempted when you go into your
kitchen
you know that's your first jihad now
you're in your kitchen and you got to be
like you're going to fail that will
power is going to you know diminish
so get it don't bring it in the house so
this is where we also need you know
uh the the family to work together
because if one's on that wavelength the
other one's not then
it becomes it's a conflict in the house
what do you say about that we need
that's huge man well i'm so glad you
touched on that point i'm so
glad you touched on that point because
it's very important for the wife and the
husband to at least respect at least
respect each other's decisions and and
and to uh
accommodate that so when you cook
something you know if you're the wife or
the husband and you're cooking something
and you know the husband does not want
uh any salt or he doesn't want anything
processed no sauce is with it
try to cook another dish for him or use
another pan if he doesn't want
you know certain types of of of you know
whether no margarine he wants natural
butter you know something like that or
coconut oil
you know when cooking you know make that
make that investment
uh for what dare i even say for the
america i've seen one particular
marriage where
it was becoming a problem i mean it was
becoming a marital
issue where the husband had a certain
diet and he wanted to try to maintain
his diet he was getting into fitness and
things of that nature and wellness
and the wife wasn't really on board and
it created it created conflict and guess
who was seeing it
the kids yeah the kids you know
so without a doubt it this requires
subhanallah
a series of meetings between the wife
and the husband
and the the the parents and the children
and it's not
it's not you know put that away it's
more
in the beginning maybe but to explain to
them why
you know like when children especially
young boys and
boys and girls when they're turning into
a man in puberty
well like sugar is one of the worst
enemies for acne is one of the causes of
acne
so if you tell them like like one of my
sons he was starting to get acne i said
leave off the barbecue sauce i know your
dad used to love it
leave off the barbecue sauce you know as
soon as he left it off
he started drinking water more water
stayed away from soda
he saw the the acne just disappear look
at that i mean look at that now
where would you go i mean again it goes
back to if you would have went to a
physician for instance which again i
don't want i want i'm just this is
because
it's very important unless you go to a
holistic minded physician
they would not connect this connect
exactly exactly
they'll make the connection but pops
made the connection
well look learning from holistic
positions man i mean i i'll tell you man
surprise
you know just just him leaving that he
understands now and now
now he's an independent thinker in
regards to his bodily function he
realizes how this
sugar plays in his life not only cause
from his cup from how he looks but even
this before he loves basketball
even in his performance he realizes it
and he sees how he gets real shut down
and lazy
and that's where i come and i'm like ah
see it was that
what you consumed it was those skills
your friend gave you you know right
before practice
right right so now it's like nah bubba i
can't
kate comes around nah above it so now
it's just okay now you understand that
and that's huge that you mentioned with
family you know subhanallah and it's not
going to come overnight
uh brothers and sisters it may not come
overnight and that's where again
it goes back to dua to allah i just want
to mention one thing that you mentioned
you mentioned it twice
the preservation of the uh the body the
preservation
this is what we call from the islamic
objectives the fastest of the sharia
some say five and some say six right
so health and eating from the bath even
falls
into more categories you know
preservation of the health
preservation uh of the of the of the of
the deen
because when you're so lethargic you
don't want to get up
for fajr you don't want to get it from
pm and late
what is one of the reasons that's
important to go
to get sleep as the scholars mentioned
is to wake up to to wake up for a baddha
to have enough energy for abadda so
everything that you use should
increase you as a means to increase you
in your ibadah and your gratefulness to
god
right so if food is not helping you in
that
it can be something that is detrimental
to your deen
to your religion you know and again as
we talked about of
not looking at you know understanding
that your body
is a temple it is a trust you don't
ultimately own it is what allah has
given you
how are you feeding it what are you
feeding it and how are you using it
so substituting those sweets there's
always something now that you can
replace if you leave
off you know and the dr madiha she
illustrates this she makes so many
different foods you know and they'll
probably be talking about this
uh she talks about it a lot in the halal
kitchen the sisters in there where
you have if you leave off for instance
let's take ice cream
and there's a video out there you can
watch from the ben and jerry's
everybody knows about ben and jerry's i
think jerry's right
of course the founders interesting story
if you go on youtube and look chris
beat cancer and then one of his guests
is
the son of the owner of that famous
ice cream chain he talks about how he
was about to inherit this he was about
to inherit the kingdom of ice cream
it up because he started turning towards
health and he saw
that the ice cream was actually helping
to destroy people's health
right so he gave it up and later
his father also got cancer among the
majority of
most of his family and then it was
interesting you got to watch this story
for people out there
you know who are really ice cream lovers
uh so you can see it for what it is
but then i'll give you a substitute to
it so then he's at the doctor's office
and the doctor recommends this book that
look how allah sets everything
up that and the book was by the author
his son
so it came back around his
to his and his son wrote i forgot the
gentleman's name but he's uh someone
who's really into what we're talking
about
so uh substituting you know the white
sugar with
you know the tiger the sweets the whole
fruits that have vitamins micronutrients
eating real food avoiding fake food i
want to go i just want to touch upon
this i think it's real important just
real quick
naps you know we all have this ego and
what not all of us
all right we have to you know be
struggling against it
but like let's say for me a martial
artist i i am uh i've done some boxing
kickboxing you know
uh my main specialty is jiu jitsu
gracious but now if i start you know
there's other
martial arts so if someone comes to me
and they start asking about filipino
martial arts with knives and this that
even though we have some basic weapons
disarmament
but if i start trans if i start getting
into an avenue like i know everything
you know what i mean
right that's feeding my ego and i'm
misleading people right i have to know
my limitations basically what i'm saying
like if i don't know something
got to say look and what does the shade
this famous statement is half an hour
just saying i just don't know
so now going back to to doctors you know
just again there's so much to learn you
know and this
i love our muslim doctors out there we
have so many different physicians but
have you ever had a conversation and
talk with you know any physicians
just to motivate them also to take it
because
look some you know people they get
into this area like okay what i learned
is the gold standard nothing else is
worthy of learning what i learned is
as is the divine religion there's
nothing else to learn and they get stuck
and that's it they don't go outside of
that and then
and take their knowledge like dr madiha
did to the next level so to motivate
them because
they're the people that people respect
us and they're going to be going to them
right so instead of just being the md
standing for
master drug dealer let us stand for
education and educating people on really
what's the key to good health and that's
good nutrition you know
yeah no definitely um so ego ego
sometimes it plays into it do you see
that
of course why they get the message and
they do that but what what have you have
any experience talking to some
physicians about this
well uh oh yeah definitely um
you know subhanallah because you know
it's two things
the first thing is that you know with
physicians when talking with them and
not to
you know as we're not doing and as you
mentioned numerous times but to make
that very very clear
this is not to downplay the profession
of being a physician or traditional
physician
but it's again going back to the issue
that you're talking about now
is to know our limits and that's why you
know when i mention certain
types of surgeons in certain professions
they're specialized which is
which is what one is supposed to do but
that means
that there is ignorance in another in
another area it's important to know
that the word doctor covers a lot of of
different
disciplines science sciences experiences
and it's just to know particularly where
we fall in that and it reminds
me this is the second thing is uh you
know uh a couple of days ago i don't
know if you know that there was a family
here
uh in allen texas that uh you know uh
two young men
uh they took their own life and took
took their families like two muslims
here in allen texas and uh you know we
as imams we all met here in dallas all
of us as imams we all met on a zoom call
and we had uh you know some
psychotherapists on there with us
and one of them made a very important
point you know it's um
and she said you know please please
please you know
you know realize that the community
members are coming to you
as imams when they are stressed
when they have a problem if they may be
suicidal they're not ultimately coming
to us they're coming to you as
imams it's important for you to know
your limits and when to
refer them to a psychotherapist
to a psychologist when to refer them and
that's very important for imams
as well you know that when you're you
know getting hired as an imam or youth
director
know what know your limits know where
you can
what what allah has given you and how
you want to help this world
and no way you say well no that's not my
profession i don't know anything about
that let me refer you to someone
you know subhanallah i remember the
hadith of the where um
two companions was three companions they
were traveling we know this hadith where
the man he had some sores i think it was
some sores on his head
right and he wanted to uh
you know have a concession he didn't
want to make ruslan
you know and they said no you have to
and the water when it hit his wounds
he eventually died from that when they
came back to the prophet salallahu they
referred they mentioned this to him
he said to muhammad he said you
all killed him right because of their
lack of knowledge
and insisting on what it was may allah
be pleased with them
but the prophet problem was making a
point here is that there was a
concession there was some element of
knowledge that should have been sought
before making this claim or before i
want to say forcing
but enforcing uh this upon the
individual so it's very very important
that you mention that
we should we should stop where we do not
know and say i don't know
and take it to the people that do no
show them absolutely just to touch upon
what you mentioned this a very sad
um tragedy that happened i just want to
touch upon it i i don't know
for for the majority of people because
we take
very dearly when we hear the term muslim
islam you know and for
just all of humanity life is just so
precious but i don't know if did you get
a chance to read
through their letter yeah the
manifestation
yeah yeah i mean it seemed like this was
more again it's another topic i want to
talk about it
they had more of a secular theology this
is like you know i mean we should use
the label that they were muslim what not
okay but what the way that in the letter
you had the way i believe they they
thought life was just about being happy
so they
did this to make their parents happy to
take them to a happy place so
it was like just antithesis to the
islamic teachings and islam i know this
is a different topic but
you know when you read through that just
calling out you know what we're being
exposed to in the schools in the secular
system and then a lot of times people
try to
put as islam as the blame but if if we
were living truly the islam
that's taught to us you know what i mean
these these uh
ideas and all these things that creep in
and all the other things i mean
uh i don't know your thoughts on that
when you read the letter you know and
and again
not to the minute and other health
issues and mental health all that stuff
playing uh but when you when you read
that what did you take from when you
read
read through their letter no it's
exactly that it's exactly what you're
talking about you know our environment
and what we put out what we
you know what we're surrounded by we've
got to be very cognizant of that on a
regular basis you know on a
on a given sunday we need to say okay
how have i spent my day
and then hold ourselves accountable um
but that ultimately goes back to
you know when it comes to our connection
with allah and what actions during the
course of our day
are we consciously doing
just understanding that relationship of
of doing an act of worship
uh and how that ties into iman so that
you know that's where i got it from
there and definitely um
it was something that you know you could
say a cry for help as well you know
to protect us inshallah i mean i mean i
mean i look i want to probably do an
episode dedicated to this
future inshallah let's go back so health
another part of health look exercise you
know this is so important so we get our
nutrition right
first we get our dean right right we get
the right we get our heart right
connected to the creator the one and
only
and then from there holistic way of life
you know we
we mentioned the ayah from the quran we
mentioned the
hadith about taking health serious
before you lose it you know uh exercise
so
what do we have to say about exercise
how has that helped you in your life are
you uh
how many days a week do you exercise
what do you recommend for people who are
just really uh even some people are
learning people you're just
used to sitting in a cubicle in the
chair you know i mean you don't get out
there
and there's no movement in the life and
if you start you don't move
you start dying man you start you start
to get into if you don't use it as say
you lose it
right right and that's literally it if
you don't use it you lose it so all the
muscles in your body that it's important
to use at some degree
now i mean when we talk about working
out you know you know
it's not about you know pumping iron or
screaming in the gym
or you know you know working out so
you're just totally
you can barely talk and breathe uh it's
just a matter of having some kind of
movement with some level of resistance
your body does not know you know uh
subhanallah
again a five gallon water bottle from
of you know a 15 pound weight or
a person that you may be trying to move
and maneuver
during jiu jitsu and wrestling right
your body doesn't know and doesn't care
it's just a matter of
are you using particular muscles in a
particular way
for you know so that's what's most
important we talk about exercise that's
all it is it's just
movement with some kind of resistance
now depending on that level of
resistance and the range of resistance
is that
is where we can get the different uh
results so for you know people that
it depends on what you want so a lot of
people talk about you know i want to
work out then
first question is ask okay what exactly
do you want
you know so if we're talking about you
know nutrition that's the first thing
that i always try to tell people is okay
what are you eating how are you sleeping
because those are the three elements
right it's
you're eating you're sleeping and you're
in your in your and you're working out
you know you really have to have the
eating somewhat be conscious of what you
eat
and understand the results of it you
know fearing the the
the punishment of it in this life and
hopefully not in the next right so it's
trying to eat clean and eating clean
means eating that which comes directly
from the earth as which we have talked
about it was being talked about but
really with
exercise it's a matter of having some
kind of movement with resistance
particularly
if you can have it around three to four
days a week depending on the exercise in
it of itself
and this is something that is highly
recommended hopefully something a little
every day from some kind of movement and
movement i'm not talking about
you know with some weight i'm talking
about a brisk walk in the morning
you know a brisk walk in the evening now
with fasting particularly
having that walk in the morning before
budget as soon as you wake up
you know studies have shown that there's
a 200 fat loss ratio when one walks in
the morning on an empty stomach
you know before they do anything and
then walking before you break your fast
as well
cardio you know cardio is just some you
know movements that
increase the heart rate uh while fasting
has shown to have
tremendous benefits as well so i mean
that's a whole you know mashallah
uh chapter in it of itself but you know
really really with exercise
it's a matter of having some kind of
movement with some kind of resistance
ultimately to have quote-unquote gains
and
i mean many many benefits from your your
heart health
uh to secretion of hormones that are
beneficial
uh such as what they call the human
human growth hormone which is secreted
from the pituitary gland
you know with weight training and adding
some resistance can help that secretion
fasting in itself helps that secretion
and i think it's going to be talked
about inshallah as we talked about
inshallah
there was a friend of mine mike lukovich
he's uh
80s and i was asking him i said what do
you do
to um keep in good health right and he
says okay he's got his own vegetable
garden here's a garden
and then what he does for exercise when
he'll run
um when he'll go get his mail from the
mailbox he sprints at his old age so
that gets the heart rate going right
he's he'll sprint that's that resistance
training he does
these are the some life hacks that i got
for him but like you said you can look
good that's one thing
from the outside but the body can be
deteriorating for inside
so it has to be built on the foundation
of good food good health we always say
eat real root
food avoid fake food the food that last
what
gave us the type of food and um exercise
have movement like you just said so
important to living a holistic
life and uh and we and we're
here with uh with dr melissa
so when we talk about doctors we're not
uh
you know just making stuff up our own
we're going to a doctor here also many
out there like this who are in that same
wavelength we got to get others
motivated inshallah
wow subhanallah that was mind-blowing
that was amazing jazakallah
both for your time and um i am so
thankful and honored that allah you guys
you know here and we can
subhanallah really educate and empower
the muslim ummah
to start with just little itty bitty
steps and i love those steps that uh
brother eddie that you said just like
get rid of the fake food just start
reading yourself educating yourself you
know
um so just it's really
powerful to try to how to like we can
just
start with these basic things right
yay also add in i i loved the
last thing you said brother eddie about
the vegetable garden i'm a huge
fan of gardening and i'm sure you guys
probably also know about the blue zones
right uh blue zones are the areas of the
world where people live to be over a
hundred
and you know they have all these
characteristics in common
of like good community sociability
um eating food that they grow
and less emphasis on materialism and
you know super stressed out life and
you know these are all teachings that we
have from islam anyway and i think
wow you know we we we can really edit
our lives down
and that would probably bring down
stress quite a bit and
simplify things and then really focus on
what's truly important
absolutely and actually have time to
exercise that we think that we don't
have time for everything right
right yeah then the guy who was running
to his mailbox i think it was
i mean that's awesome it doesn't have to
be like yeah he's in his 80s
yeah it doesn't have to be going to the
gym uh signing up for
you know people sometimes i think make
things more we make things more
complicated for ourselves sometimes
right like gardening is a i think it's a
mental therapy for me but when i
actually get in to do it
it's like it's physical work
does it work guys right there just
gardening man that's that's yeah just
out of it
it's a lot of work yeah but you've got
and increasing the microbiome like the
diversity of the microbiome
i mean we've got a problem in our stores
right we don't you know everybody wants
perfect vegetables and fruit but most
places you go in the world
i mean when i was living in turkey i had
to like wash things
many many times to get the dirt off but
that's okay you know like
you get some of that biome that's fine
you're not gonna die from that
it's you know that's it just feels more
real anyway
you know that it's that it's coming from
right right from the farm and
you know yeah it's beautiful
i mean subhanallah you mentioned
gardening i hope you'll have something
in the future a session just on that i
mean
the dean of islam i mean for children
you know my mother used to garden with
you know
we're trying to garden now i mean we
have the mint leaves that grow but
you know there's nothing like when a
child puts a seed in and then sees a
couple of weeks
later again grow and then they cut that
tomato
and then they eat it and they see how
with the work of allah subhanahu
wata'ala and with
just their hard work itself house
subhanallah it brings something organic
and that's beneficial to them and then
the process just goes on and on you know
they will eat it
i i've done as when i was a teacher i i
had
to i was i had a curriculum that was
pretty open i could do what i wanted
with it it's not a lot was an
awesome experience because what i really
wanted was the kids to be outside in
nature
um and and so it gave them all the
plastic cups some seeds
and they were so excited for the longest
time
watching everything grow and then what
happens after that
well they want to eat that fruit that
they grew or that tomato
and then they you know it becomes part
of their diet
because they invested in it you know
and then they get to see the miracle of
something that grows from just a seed
and sun and wind and
allah aloha you know that's the stuff
that
i think the lessons are so packed in
there but the
the actual doing of it is so simple
awesome
for your time today i can't wait to
continue this conversation again and
chill in another
seminar i think we have a lot more to
talk about
this is wonderful thank you guys so much
time to go yeah i mean you can stay
you want to join the group man i
could've talked about this all day
i think we're all like that in that camp
right quick
i've gathered everybody alhamdulillah
coming on next alhamdulillah
with um uh dr ahmed and sister jill i
mean all of us i feel like that's why i
wanted to gather everybody together we
can talk about this all day because
subhanallah we've we've reaped the
benefit of this
lifestyle and we we want to spread the
word so jazakallahu for
all your time today and challenge we'll
continue this conversation again and
shall another time
yeah thank you for carrying your wisdom
with everybody and
let's make it a point to do something
again and
uh i like the gardening idea maybe
exactly
i'm serious i love it i love it a lot of
my readers are
i post a lot of pictures of flowers and
things and i think well maybe people
think that's boring but i get a lot of
people asking like please do more of
that they love it
so it's something earthy we all it's
like a fit on our fit
right we exactly we really need that
kind of thing that
reconnection so let's regroup and uh
maybe after eid inshallah we can we can
talk about something to do
that's a great idea getting out of the
concrete jungle as i call it
nature connects you
wonderful uh thank you dr dsa for
hosting us your sister thank you so much
and share
really nice to see you hopefully we see
each other again soon in person
thank you